hey what's up everybody it's Warren and
we have a pretty awesome leak today so
not too long ago we got some pretty big
leaks about the descriptions for some
Avengers LEGO sets well some leaked
photos of those have actually come out
and with those leaks came war machines
war destroyer armor now the picture of
this Lego leaked for war machines war
destroyer armor have already been taken
down from all of the instagrams the
Twitter's the reddit's so that basically
confirms that these leaks were real
so it's believed that war machine will
actually have more than one type of
armor in Avengers endgame he was
actually supposed to have two different
armors and Avengers infinity war
according to concept illustrator Phil
Saunders this is what Phil had to say
originally Rhodey was going to have two
different armors in this movie and then
this ultimately got narrowed down to one
armor so the best elements in both
armors were combined into one we really
wanted to give him a much more advanced
look than what he had had in the
previous movie to keep up a little bit
with the leap from the mark 47 to mark
50 for Iron Man so I went with a much
more sophisticated stealth geometry and
breakup of the form language I also gave
him a far more extensive package of
weaponry than he had ever previously had
so as you just heard war machine was
supposed to have two different suits and
Avengers infinity war and now we have
leaks for the war machine destroyer
armor and the war machine crusher that I
mentioned in a previous video
the war machine crusher is actually
believed to be some sort of a vehicle
that can actually attach to war machine
much like Veronica formed around Iron
Man to make the Hulkbuster suit but the
war machine destroyer is actually
something from Marvel vs. Capcom the war
destroyer is an attack one of war
machines hyper combos in Marvel vs.
Capcom where war machine launches a ton
of missiles into the sky that eventually
fall down on his opponent and since
there is a leak for a war destroyer
armor it seems like war machine is going
to be getting a huge upgrade in Avengers
endgame and what's really interesting
about this leak is the war destroyer is
taken from Marvel vs. Capcom it's a
hyper combo move much like the proton
cannon we've been stating for a while
that we believe the proton cannon will
be in a
in game and war machine will use it well
since war machine is going to be getting
a war destroyer armor and since we know
from Phil Saunders that war machine is
going to be getting a huge weaponry
upgrade there's a good chance that we'll
be seen the proton cannon and Avengers
endgame we've already seen leaks of war
machine getting new armor and now we
have leaks of the war machine crusher
and the war machine war destroyer armor
so it seems like war machine is going to
be a big heavy hitter in avengers
endgame so let me know what you think
about this leak are you excited to see
war machine get a big armor and weaponry
upgrade and do you think we'll see him
use the proton cannon in avengers
endgame let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and I'm still giving
away a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet if
you would like to enter the giveaway for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]